early on it just
as the clinical trials were still
progressing and then at the very
earliest time when they started
deploying this it became clear that
uh one of the adverse there was two in
particular that were popping up
that my buddies at the FDA who were
outside of the review branch
that I was having weekly zooms with
uh said we're being flagged and I was
hearing it popping up from other
Physicians
one was uh
myocarditis
which uh the FDA and the CDC denied
in the Israelis denied that's the story
uh
and how that how that finally came uh
became public uh and the other one
was reactivation of latent DNA viruses
uh um shingles being a notable example
um and uh so there's a number of these
large herpes-like DNA viruses that exist
in our bodies for most of us
cytomegalovirus is another one
Epstein-Barr virus is a major one
and generally your T cells keep these
guys you can think of it as Pandora's
Box keeps the lid shut
um by you know T Cell suppression
and if you if you pull that suppression
off the top pops open and and all the
nasties fly out of Pandora's Box I think
is a good way to think about these
latent DNA viruses and it was clear that
that was happening after the Jab
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is a
global clinical research scholar at
Harvard Medical School a scientist an
author a speaker a bioethicist and the
inventor of mRNA vaccine technology Dr
Robert Malone welcome to the Reuben
report thank you so much uh it's lovely
to see you here today on this rather
cold Saturday here in in Virginia but
it's sunny and and it's uh you know it's
looking like it's going to be a good
year I think and you mentioned to me
that you were just out on the farm so
you're dressed down a bit for your
average podcast appearance yeah I I had
I'm sorry I I this didn't get on the
schedule somehow and I've got a bunch of
hay and straw that I have to stack we
have a a young foal in the barn that's
that's a little sketchy and it's going
to be a cold night so we want to make
sure he's well bedded down nice well
then we'll use your time well so that
you can get to that uh you know so when
I was doing some research for this
interview your bio
is basically pages and pages I mean we
just picked some highlights there but I
was trying to remember some of the
chronology of these last couple years
which have gotten very weird in light
and I'm actually I'm to say the least to
say the least and I'm actually not sure
if I had heard surreal yeah exactly we
are we are in The Matrix now but I'm
actually not sure if I had heard of you
before that famous or inFAMOUS uh
appearance on Joe Rogan so maybe before
we get to what's happened for the last
couple years do you want to just give us
a little bit of recap of your career
before that that led to this moment and
then that's really where I want to spend
most of the interview well I'm I I don't
want to belabor this too much uh I'm a
physician and a scientist trained at UC
San Diego Salk Institute UC Davis and
Northwestern University Medical School
and Harvard University Medical School so
that's the high level
uh I'm I'm a
passion been passionate about molecular
biology and virology pretty much my
whole career and uh also virology uh
with the vaccine emphasis which is kind
of uh what's brought me into the current
and uh my focus back when I was a
graduate student was trying to
understand some fundamentals about RNA
structure function and particularly how
RNA gets inserted into a retrovirus
and in order to ask fundamental
questions I had to design ways to make
large quantities of purified RNA and put
it into cells and detect its presence
and blah blah blah and it just happened
I was in a gene therapy lab working on
gene therapy projects when I had this
series of discoveries that made me aware
that there was a potential to use RNA as
a drug
and of the various applications for a
gene therapy or Gene delivery system
that doesn't actually work very well
that being with the ketonic lipids uh
um the the kind of entry-level
application was vaccines and so that was
the origin of the DNA and the RNA
vaccine idea
uh fast forward through uh you know a
decade and a half of Academia at UC
Davis School of pathology
um Maryland school of pathology both
teaching medical schools uh medical
students I'm sorry at uh pathology and
then Armed Forces University the Health
Sciences where I helped set up the
clinical Breast Care Program in a
research institute in Windber
Pennsylvania
uh I then
um uh started a company called anovio
that's still running that was largely
based on my own technology and that of
others in the field at the time and uh
then the planes hit the towers the
investors for innovio pulled back
uh my wife and I were left high and dry
in Rockville
and I reached out to a buddy at the uh
business and economic development office
at you at Maryland state and he said hey
there's this new company up in Frederick
Maryland that I could probably make a
phone call and you could get a job at
uh that was dyingport vaccine company
which had just received what the
technical term is the Prime Systems
contract for all biodefense products for
the U.S Department of Defense and so I
became their associate Clinical Director
and basically was involved in clinical
research on virtually all
drugs vaccines and monoclonal antibody
products that the dod was developing for
biodefense
and that was really the pivot point in
my career where I shifted from being a
discovery research guy
uh in the finally had the realization
that uh the world really doesn't need
more uh academic thought leaders it has
plenty of those but what it does need is
people who can uh bridge the gap uh it's
actually called the Valley of Death
technically uh a term Phil Russell
employed
between the discovery part and actually
making a product
and I decided that I had spent enough
time uh
various euphemisms come to mind
um uh let's say a chasing Academia uh
and um uh decided that I wanted to
actually try to make things that made
people's lives better uh and resulted in
products
so I've shifted gears and really focused
on uh learning the the trade of clinical
development uh
um Regulatory Affairs project management
proposal development that whole toolkit
that goes into being able to
uh assemble teams to solve complicated
problems and get them funded in in the
space of the government uh in
particularly Department of Defense
and I've I've been study section share
on on many large uh contract bid uh
selection processes I've uh served the
government in writing uh solicitations
I've uh and then eventually I set up my
own Consulting practice
kind of got tired of working for
corporate America I'd worked for a Bill
and Linda Gates
funded company called Aeris Global TV
vaccine Foundation also path in Seattle
uh worked for work for Solvay on as
their Clinical Director for influenza
vaccines
um you know many of these kind of things
I just got tired of working for
corporate and having to toe the line and
do the eight to five so I uh set up a
Consulting practice and that's kind of
what I've done ever since but given my
background I'm I'm known as a specialist
in like I said assembling teams to solve
complicated problems and being really
Adept at working at the interface
between industry and the government
uh that's a that's an area that's really
hard to navigate not very many people
have that whole skill set maybe very
very few that that understand regulatory
fairs and clinical development and all
the other stuff and uh can talk gummy
talk uh but also can talk to the private
sector and and work with them
so that was kind of my thing and and
I've been involved in many outbreaks uh
was right at the tip of the spear and
Drug repurposing for zika
uh um uh was really asked by the
Department of Defense and defense
reduction agency to step in and solve a
hot mess that was a small Midwestern
company that owned the rights to a z uh
I'm sorry a Ebola vaccine candidate that
they bought from Canada for about a
hundred fifty thousand dollars
um and I carried that forward that was a
you know amazing time everybody people
were scared out of their brains Ebola is
a scary business way more scary than
than the Corona and uh
it drives people crazy uh and uh you
know they'll they'll shoot each other
and a ball is a scary disease and uh so
I got Merck involved in that project and
got them to buy the product from the
small Midwestern company and that's now
the merkabola vaccine
so been doing this a long time and uh
then then and when you're in this space
you touch on the intelligence Community
all the time
uh they are all thick throughout
biodefense
and so I've had many contacts that have
been CIA I'm not CIA I'm not trained CIA
I have been security cleared by the
Department of Defense I'm sorry Stu
Peters uh you're wrong on that uh and
George Webb but there it is uh yeah you
know and uh so if you're in this
business area you you touch on CIA folk
all the time and uh I've actually
co-published with one that is now a
retired CAA officer who arguably
is our top expert in gain of function
research
uh former project manager at DARPA named
Dr Michael Callahan who has an
appointment at Harvard
and uh
and he called me up on January 2nd 2020
or January 4th right around there and
said hey Robert we got a problem this
novel coronavirus looks that's
circulating here in Wuhan looks like
it's going to be a problem and that's
what got me going
uh and that's kind of where the the
Journey of the last three years begins
and I did a threat assessment as I
always do he asked me to get my the
group that I work with kind of wound up
and ready to respond to this
and uh I I did the usual threat
assessment and my sense was that we
could not build a safe and effective
vaccine in time to really make an impact
as this would move as a wave across the
globe
and that what we needed to focus on was
a repurposed drugs so that's pretty much
what I did for the first third of the
last two years uh largely with DOD
funding which I'm a kind of adroit at
getting I captured I don't know 300
million um for various projects uh
relating to drug repurposing
and then uh actually the there was a
series of kind of uh red pill moments
uh and you mentioned Joe Rogan before
Joe Rogan uh there was the moment when I
got called by Steve Kirsch to uh go on a
podcast with this guy never heard of
before I had hardly even heard of
podcasting uh and and this guy uh he the
name of his podcast was kind of scary I
thought it referred to the dark web it
was the Dark Horse podcast and his name
was Brett Weinstein Brett Brett is a
good friend of mine and and I I was the
first one that ever publicly interviewed
him after he left Evergreen State or
when he was in the midst of that now
over there yeah yes so they we all kind
of sat around that little table three
old men and and talked for a couple
hours and uh the world went crazy right
so okay now now having reminded me of
that of course I knew of you before the
Rogan thing it's hard these last couple
of years have been real fast but all
right so let's pause there for a second
because that'll kind of set us up for
for the last you know two and a half
years or so and and thank you for doing
some of the bio stuff so I didn't have
to read all of that but what I wanted to
illustrate there was that you've got
sort of the private sector you've got
the government sector something related
at least closely enough non-governmental
organization so you know I kind of been
around the block three or four four
times Academia so so with all of that in
mind let's just do some like basic 101
stuff for a moment before we get to your
red pill moment when when people are
talking about vaccines and and the
difference between the these mRNA
vaccines and how we've always done
vaccines previously can you give us just
like a like a high level version of that
and and sort of when did you become
concerned that there was a difference in
what was going on here
so I think what you're talking about is
not what is the nature of a vaccine in
terms of the technology but rather what
is the process to bring a vaccine to
Market
and that's typically about a 10-year
timeline
to illustrate the point the Department
of Defense if everything goes well and
it never does is on track to have
vaccines licensed for all uh
infectious disease agents that were
deployed in BIO Warfare up until the end
of World War II and if everything goes
right they'll have all those vaccines by
2050. a full Century after the end of
World War II okay so we gotta we got a
basically a 10 10-year timeline to
really do it right
and that involves a significant
non-clinical research toxicology
pharmacody distribution
genotoxicity a whole bunch of things
that just got blown off
uh to make sure that that it's safe
enough to go into humans in the first
place
and then once it's in humans It Go
typically a vaccine goes through a very
staged process of phase one trials
typically a couple of different phase
one trials phase two expanded trials
phase one is typically just kind of
preliminary estimates of safety with low
numbers you know here's an important
thing to know uh in vaccinology we use
the rule of three
um and and the way this works is if you
want to detect an adverse event that
occurs in one in a thousand people
generally you have to test 3 000 people
if you wanted to text something that
happens 1 in 30
okay or one in ten I was going to say
one and ten then you'd have to test 30
people okay so that's kind of phase one
trial right level one and you know one
in ten is stuff that happens a lot
pretty much to everybody Right One In A
Thousand is is something that matters a
lot if you're going to be administering
it to large populations which generally
is the case with vaccines unless you're
talking about Special Forces or
something for some obscure pathogen uh
and then when you really get to uh you
know Global deployment or national
deployment you want to have sample sizes
in the kind of three hundred thousand uh
range uh you know this is what the FDA
is typically required in the past for
um uh new adjuvants for example for a
vaccine
but in this case kind of all the rules
went out the door in the rush uh in all
the fear that was actively promoted
uh in
so when you when you do it that stepwise
fashion and then typically what happens
is you you first kind of move it forward
in healthy normal adults
because they have lowest risks they can
handle insults biologic insults best
and then then you move to elderly people
and special populations like
immunosuppressed and those kinds of
things and you do a step down into the
little babies okay so first you do
adolescence and then you do especially
young adults and you do adolescents then
you do children then you do uh you know
young very young and then you can go
down to neonates if you have to
so that's the general process and to do
all that takes enormous amount of time
and the cost per subject
uh for a well-run trial is something it
starts at about ten thousand per person
generally if you if you really mind your
nickels you can get it down to about
five or eight thousand per person and it
goes up to about thirty or forty
thousand per person so you can do the
math and uh you quickly come up to some
serious serious cash uh so it it takes
you know billions of dollars
um years and years to do this safely
and uh as you've seen the decision was
to rush the whole thing
uh bypass almost everything
um and uh started ministering it into
a a very broad population a global
population
and do so
also bypassing this key thing that was
we all agreed on in the Western World at
least after World War II
uh called the Nuremberg Accords and the
Helsinki Accords uh and then in in
moving to the present
um we call this the common rule
in which people have to have be granted
informed consent and you absolutely
cannot uh coerce compel or entice
uh people to take an unlicensed medical
product that is just historically been
off limits we all agreed nope Germans
did that that you know everybody thinks
about what happened in Nazi Germany uh
the story of what happened in Japan is
even uglier
uh the Japanese biowarfare program was
uh you know truly atrocious in terms of
the bioethics
and uh as I guess Bobby is going to
point out in his next book
Bobby Kennedy uh just like we imported a
lot of the rocket scientists uh to
launch NASA so to speak uh we imported
both German but particularly the
Japanese biowarfare experts and the
records associated with that uh up to
Fort Detrick in Frederick Maryland to
launch our bio Warfare program
which after Nixon made the determination
that we were going to put in place the
um biowarfare treaty uh got transformed
into a biodefense program the same
people doing the same stuff pretty much
uh and that's that's kind of where
that's all gone it's it's not a pretty
picture
uh and and the deeper you look into it
in the bio Labs that we set up in
Georgia the former Soviet state and then
presumably the bio Labs that we set up
in Ukraine
uh
those those uh offshore bio Labs uh
have a long Rich history of ethical
abuses let's say gently
um so it's it's a it's a mixed bag here
um there's a lot of
there's there's I I do believe that
there is an unmet need
uh and that was the logic for advancing
the RNA Tech in theory
was there absolutely is an unmet need
for ability to respond rapidly to
engineered pathogens and emerging
infectious disease but uh
I
I think personally that what's been done
will basically destroy Global public
confidence in any of this kind of
activity for the foreseeable future yeah
I think I think we've done that already
and God only knows where that leaves us
when when something really big hits but
so I want to back up for a second so
when you got that call around the second
or fourth of of January of January back
in 2020 now warp speed was basically a
couple of months later what were you
warned what were you warning about at
that point I mean were you basically
trying to get information to the
administration to say don't rush this
thing because God only knows what's
going to happen or what the vaccine
injuries are going to be Etc et cetera
putting aside the coercion and yeah so
so actually uh Callahan I I sent we we
launched a drug Discovery program uh
involving repurposed drugs that was
absolutely Cutting Edge uh computational
modeling we screen the entire library of
all known licensed drugs as well as
nutraceuticals
and we came up with a ranked list of
Agents
and then I was at a drug Discovery
conference involving artificial
intelligence and machine learning at MIT
in the end of February 2020
and I got infected with the original
Wuhan strain in that first wave that
moved through uh Boston
and came home uh wasn't even aware that
the virus had hit Boston at that point
we all thought it was in Seattle
and uh
you know starting to trickle into New
York and um
my wife came in and as I'm laying sick
as a dog in the bed and said hey Robert
you know what you probably caught this
one
and at that point as somebody with the
background of pathology and working with
a very strong team
uh
uh including other Pathologists I I was
of the belief that this was this was
likely to be lethal
or at a minimum uh to cause a
progressive interstitial pulmonary
fibrosis which is basically to say
lingering death uh from uh loss of lung
function
and uh so that was kind of grim uh and
and I started that's what that's just
what you were feeling just based on how
you felt at the time that yeah and I was
sick I was really sick and
um
uh burning lungs uh
um you know lots lots of symptoms and um
so I I was embarrassed to do it but out
of desperation I started taking the
drugs that we'd identified
uh it's generally not kosher to
experiment on yourself in terms of
medical ethics
but you know you're lying here there's
no drugs there's no docs that know how
to treat it here in Virginia
um they didn't even have any testing uh
you know I called up to Public Health
Service and said hey I need to get the
definitive diagnosis and they said well
if you think you have it you probably do
um yeah that was about it uh in February
so then you test on yourself like every
bad guy in a Marvel movie basically yeah
I started trying the drugs and the and I
tried everybody's really hot on um
quercetin uh it's in many of the
protocols for me of course it's in a
nice of course attendant was just a bust
nothing
uh but I took famotidine this uh Pepcid
drug and suddenly you know within an
hour I had a clinical response my lungs
stopped burning I could breathe better
and I was like okay this is kind of uh
important so we really chased the tail
on that one
and eventually got it into clinical
trials and and got papers published and
some couldn't get published uh once they
started blocking all publication of
repurposed drugs
and we uh continued on and and uh uh in
a contract with MIT Lincoln Labs really
uh identified react and stacked a whole
bunch of agents that we're all familiar
with now
um for uh you know the dod potentially
for the Warfighter
and then uh and then this Buzz started
with the with the Jabs and what had been
done with ows
and uh people started contacting me for
information because everybody was
confused and intimidated by This Acronym
RNA Mr what does this all mean you know
um you know no one would talk uh and so
it was uh ring up Robert Malone and and
hope he could shed some light and that's
that's what kind of set that ball
rolling
um so that that I hope that fills in
some of the gaps for you yeah so so as
now they're rolling out warp speed and
you realize that this technology that
you were one of the experts on and had
the patents on all this stuff and
everything else as you realize that this
is going to be now pushed really on on
everyone in America with all this uh you
know the companies were gonna have no
liability and all of this crazy stuff
what was your first red pill moment
related to that when did you realize
that something was wrong here well I
realized something was wrong when uh the
book that my wife
put together in February
really in January and published in the
beginning of February uh called how to
prepare and protect yourself from the
novel Coronavirus
got censored in March and taken to
Amazon
uh so that that and and the
justification it took us forever to
finally get them to fess up as to why
because their usual policies they'll
tell you you know oh there's porn on
page 52 or whatever the thing is right
you fat shamed somebody whatever your
sin is they'll usually tell you yeah
um they wouldn't tell us although in the
case of covet a little fat shaming
probably would help but okay yeah but
that's not allowed these days uh so
any case uh finally uh the other shoe
drops
um we have violated Community standards
what are those Community standards
undefined but we we violated them okay
so that's the first time I ever heard
that phrase and and so it went uh
there was a series of things but in
terms of the Jab
uh
a couple of key things both of which
involved Canadians
uh really
um crystallize things for me
I got a
um
a call about
uh
from really out of desperation from a
Canadian physician practicing Toronto
who wants to be not named
uh his his office has been broken in his
computer has been Trashed by the
government I mean he's totally been
targeted for the sin of uh
prescribing Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and saving people's
lives
uh but uh he called me in
uh with brokered by Steve Kirsch uh and
on a a Saturday evening
uh seems forever go
and
was just appealing to me hoping that I
could get through to the Canadian
regulatory authorities
and help help them understand what was
really going on
he you know kind of naively and and
um and I had already managed I had
already called in and had conversations
and was had ongoing conversations with
senior people at the FDA
but uh I don't know anybody in the
Canadian regulatory Authority and I
don't even know the Canadian regs that
well and so I had to say to him uh you
know we we had this long conversation
where he was telling me about
how they were deleting any records that
he would enter having to do with Adverse
Events of his patients after they took
the Jab
and just totally disregarding what he
was observing clinically
and furthermore they were the government
was enticing children to take the jab
with ice creams
and and for me this was an ethical
horror I never heard of anything like
this you know this is what I've been
trained to never do
uh you know on pain of losing my ability
to ever practice clinical research again
and uh
so I I had to tell him I it's just we we
talked until midnight and I said there's
nothing I can do for you I just don't
know I don't know who to call I don't
know what to say
and I woke up in the morning and uh my
wife and I are both well trained in
bioethics
uh My Mentor in bioethics was her PhD
Mentor a guy named edel Shamu
and uh
and I woke up and I said Jill I know
what we can do for this poor guy
uh we can publish an article
on uh the bioethics of what's going on
with these vaccines
and the failure to enable informed
consent and the enticement and coercion
and what is the history of the bioethics
rules that apply Etc
and uh so that was that was the first
big one and I think that was the first
article out that really drilled into
what was going on wrong with the
bioethics
and so basically so basically you first
were concerned just about informed
consent this is before you had any sense
of what the vaccine injuries might be
right so this is so so at that point I'm
skating on thin ice
I'm hearing these injuries
uh and
um I know I'm seeing the amazings that's
going on
and uh
in gaslighting and you know information
control and everything blacklisting
that's going on
and so I'm trying to figure out okay how
can I navigate this this minefield
and uh say something that will move the
ball forward and get everybody to see
that this this isn't right what's going
on without just getting you know my head
cut off and labeled as a anti-vaxxer nut
case uh you know obviously I didn't
succeed very well in that
um uh but uh that was that was the
attempt was to thread the needle yeah
and I thought that bioethics was
something where I clearly had the cork
expertise and competence I was
absolutely on the right I mean there's
no ifs ands or buts about this topic uh
in in terms of what is right and proper
and so I thought well this is one thing
I can do here
that uh should be able to penetrate
through the mainstream media
and uh get people away so that's that's
what I focused on and that's focused on
uh for quite a few months was just
trying to uh be the voice of responsible
bioethics and drive that home
and and was any of that breaking through
to mainstream media I actually don't
recall seeing you yeah I was gonna say I
don't recall seeing you on CNN or on uh
Meet the Press or anything so basically
yeah so so you try that for a while and
then and then in parallel
uh u-pin and uh bioentec
were aggressively marketing to uh
characters for the Nobel Prize
Katie courico and Drew Weissman
and uh Katie is a former Hungarian spy
and Drew is a former Tony fauci postdoc
both of whom ended up working at UPenn
and there this is about a decade later
from after what I did my work
and they had this discovery that they
could use pseudo-uridine in the RNA and
get more immune response
and they were being marketed
aggressively because this is what you
know this is one way to play the game if
you want to get a Nobel Prize for your
Institution
uh as as the inventors of this whole
technology and concept and I was just
kind of pissed about being written out
of History
uh and so I objected to that then this
huge marketing campaign came at me about
um oh you you're absolutely not the
inventor
um you're lying you're misrepresenting
you know you're risk misrepeting your CV
and and uh and it's all about Katie and
Drew and uh you know New York Times and
CNN interviews for them and everything
and so I I just became a very
inconvenient uh uh squeaky wheel in that
whole environment and then when I'm
coming out with this messaging about
bioethics
I was already kind of uh uh got the
black spot
despite having worked with media for uh
almost two decades usually on background
the reason why you never heard of me
before is there I I have had multiple
hard lessons in the uh
the wisdom of the common DC saying uh if
they can't see you they can't shoot you
uh and and I I've you know as a
consultant I've been able to do what I
did by staying behind the scenes letting
my clients take the credit and uh just
kind of laying low and getting my
business done and collecting my fee
uh so that was a long-standing
intentional strategy Department of
Defense in particular but most clients
really don't like to have uh the
consultant
um uh be out front
uh so
right so you have the initial issue is
the coercion then the vaccines are out
you already had heard of some uh vaccine
injuries and things of that nature yeah
other Canadian comes in Byram
so Byram uh who I'd never heard of
before but he's an absolutely well
qualified vaccinologist immunologist uh
academic University of
uh gelf is that right I think
um I may be confusing him with Matthias
Desmond uh so forgive me if I did uh so
Byram
apparently manages to grab
the common technical document for the
Pfizer uh
um submission uh for allowance to
proceed in humans
uh so common technical document we used
to call those inds it's the dossier of
everything they know about the product
uh in that they use to justify
initiating clinical trials
and uh and usually those are considered
confidential so the likes of you and I
can't get at them uh because otherwise
we would be able to go and try to
reverse engineer whatever the new
product is
and so for whatever reason the Japanese
apparently put this you know Common
technical document is basically a
universal document that gets submitted
to all Regulatory Agencies all over the
world
and they put it on a server and Byram
had somehow grabbed it or one of his
buddies had and sent it to him and he'd
done an analysis of it uh most of it's
in Japanese but the figures and legends
are in English
and so he went through that and he was
pretty shocked by what he found
but he's not a Regulatory Affairs expert
and he doesn't have the kind of you know
hybrid experience I have
so he asked a buddy of mine that runs a
company called trial site news
to uh see whether or not I would take a
look at it
so it comes to me right after it goes to
Byram and I'm asked to do an independent
assessment
uh and and I read through the thing and
I'm pretty shocked
uh and uh and how how shoddy it is it's
just it's atrocious
and um shocking uh to me that this would
be submitted for anything I mean if I
submitted that I would expect to get
reprimanded if not uh basically tarred
and feathered by the FDA
um was that basic was that because of
the efficacy of what you were seeing
what what was the most shock it was just
there was no real efficacy data they
weren't even testing the real drug
product they were substituting an mRNA
coding for a firefly protein luciferase
um they so it was the mythology the
methodology of the whole thing basically
no it was it was completely inadequate
by any standards that I had been trained
on completely inadequate as a package
and so I wrote up my assessment and I
was so concerned by what I thought I saw
you know this can't possibly be coming
from Pfizer this can't possibly be you
know I must be missing something so I
sent it to a more senior Regulatory
Affairs guy that I know
that I used to work with in another
contract research organization and he
looked it over and he said oh yeah
Robert everything you've said here is
true but you missed a couple of other uh
and and so I said well okay that's great
I need to write this up now as an essay
uh for trial site news do you want your
name on it he's like no no no no no
don't put my name anywhere anywhere near
this thing uh so I boldly uh went where
uh Angels Fear To Tread uh and and put
that thing out uh in
um Byram in parallel put his out
and I've I've since met and spent time
with Byram he tells the story uh up in
Canada that uh he was scared silly of
what I was gonna say he thought I was
this big intimidating nasty guy and I
was going to tear him to shreds and when
I basically piped up on the on the zoom
call that we had over this and said
Byram I agree with everything you've
said plus there's these other things he
was completely relieved but that's
that's how that came to be is is that's
how I ended up being one of the first if
not the first to me and Byram at least
to really break the story that the
regulatory package that Pfizer had
submitted was grossly inadequate that
set off a Cascade of me talking to Peter
marks and you know I at that point I was
still assuming that uh the FDA was
acting in good faith
uh and and my core assumption was that
Pfizer had pulled a fast one on the FDA
that the FDA didn't have sufficient
scientific expertise to understand what
they were looking at they couldn't
possibly there's no way this could get
through the FDA the only way I could
imagine would be if they if the people
that were doing the reviewing
just didn't understand what they were
looking at
and so I offered my help to Peter marks
and said you know I understand all this
Tech and uh he basically told me to go
pound sand and uh and that another uh
body of data had been submitted by
Pfizer and he'd reviewed that and he
actually asked me to be quiet about my
concerns
uh to give him time to disclose uh what
was in this new Pfizer dossier
which we now know the FDA and Pfizer
tried to withhold from the public for 75
years until the courts forced them to
and so basically I got lied to by Peter
marks but that uh now in retrospect
shouldn't surprise me
what's so fascinating about this beyond
the science that's obviously fascinating
is that you're sort of laying out the
story of your red pilling in essence
because every step of the way here
there's some Regulatory Commission or
some sort of censorious uh Outlet that's
that's kind of stopping you or that even
there you still are saying you had this
belief that the FDA would stop it so
when did when did you realize that it
sort of seemed like the entire Machinery
was either broken or my words just
outright negligent
uh
that's a that's a good question
um
as the
Adverse Events piled up
and and I I'm vaccine injured
uh I took the jab I took moderna when
the um uh National Guard was deploying
it here in Central Virginia
I was scheduled for a talk in France and
I knew I couldn't go if I didn't take
the Jab
and I had long covet and there was a
whole lot of press that long covet could
be could benefit from taking the jab we
now know that's a lie
um but uh you know more probably how
skeptical were you I mean knowing
knowing that you had had covet okay you
had long coveted but you had done
research I mean how skeptical were you
oh yeah so I I had number one
in good faith
I'd assumed that my colleagues that I
had known for decades
must have had
another part of the story that we didn't
cover is that Jill and I worked on this
tech for over a decade in Academia
in uh at California regional private
Research Center at bounce Labs at
um Maryland
uh and we abandon it because we could
never overcome the toxicity
and we have multiple other patents I
mean this wall behind me is all patents
um multiple other patents for different
candidac lipids uh different
formulations uh we published the first
stuff on use of cholesterol which is in
these formulations and uh early on I
called up uh the guy at um University of
British Columbia uh Peter Cullis who I'd
known for quite a while who was the one
that had really made the breakthroughs
to enable this uh this version that was
being deployed
and uh I had faith that they had solved
those problems that we had not been able
to solve
uh so
um I was still operating assuming that
that they had overcome the things that
had bedeviled us
that's a heck of a leap of faith huh
well I think it's reasonable I mean you
can assume that people are are nefarious
or you can assume that people are
generally good
I and I prefer to assume that people are
although I gotta say the last three
years that's taken a pretty hard hit uh
yeah but I still I still approach the
world with an open heart I try hard to
and I and and I try hard to have faith
in my fellow man and
um and I employ the three strikes rule
generally speaking uh you know uh takes
three strikes for me to say I just don't
want to deal with that person again
um so so yeah I I
extended Trust
uh to my former colleagues
believing that they must have had the
Breakthrough that they asserted that
they had had
uh and uh obviously in retrospect
they had
convinced themselves as a as a community
of a number of things such as minor
modifications in the structure of the
positively charged fat would lead to
formulations which would Target specific
organ systems or tissues
and so they they had published and it
was believed in the field that these uh
modified versions and I we we in my lab
we built hundreds of different cadetic
lipid compounds and tested them at gen
sign they they tested thousands or tens
of thousands
uh when they were trying to get agents
to treat cystic fibrosis
so I I knew how the game was played and
and I the the literature suggested that
uh there had been some kind of
serendipitous magic findings that if you
use this structure and you injected it
it would only go to the lymph nodes and
it would stay there and you'll recall
that's what we were all told
um and yet uh
that wasn't true it was clearly not true
based on the Pfizer data package that
Byron Bridal had obtained uh so
you know when you're when you're in
you know you spent your whole career
working in an area
you have all these relationships with
people
uh professional relationships
to break out of that
and and say oh you know all these things
I thought were this way were wrong and
for me uh so I not only had that on kind
of a micro level in this little bubble
of this technology
but I think we've all had that those of
us that are awake have had that same
experience uh about our government uh
media
um uh military all you know uh um
globalism uh you know the I was our I
knew the World Health Organization was
corrupt as the day is long because I'd
been there a number of times and spoken
and dealt with them but
um but the scope of what we've been
dealing with I think for all of us
pretty much uh we'd we just at least I
had assumed that uh the world was a very
different place and that people acted
with Integrity generally speaking
I wrote a a essay about this on sub
stack where I talked about
um
uh peeling off layers of naivete
uh and and I'm still not sure I've
peeled off all the layers of my diet I'm
sure there's there's more to go but
there's there's always another layer
there's always another layer so so all
of this is happening and now you're
you're being red pilled because you're
seeing it through not only colleagues
but you're seeing it through the
regulatory commissions
myself okay I on jab two I developed
hypertension to 230 systolic and and pod
narcolepsy and restless leg and you know
all those at the time were not cataloged
as as Adverse Events but we now know
that they are
um so so I saw you uh I saw a clip of
you on Twitter a few weeks ago that no
longer exists but I saw it with my own
eyes so unless it was a deep fake I saw
it it was not from your account it was
from someone else's account where in
essence what you were saying was and
clean this up for me if I'm if I'm
getting it slightly wrong that that
basically some level of the MRNA vaccine
is sort of like a low-grade HIV in that
it is degrading people's immune systems
it's it's hitting the T cells so now
other dormant viruses are now popular
that was that's not a deep
um I don't know that I use the reference
to AIDS only if I did it would be a
reference to uh in autoimmune uh or I'm
sorry
deficiency syndrome
um yes you you made a point of of
differentiating between HIV and AIDS yes
so uh acquired immunodeficiency syndrome
is the is what the and so if you
do something you know you're in in a
state and then you then something
happens and you become more
immunodeficient you've acquired an
immunode deficiency syndrome right so
that's that's the tie-in it aids is
actually a big basket into which you can
throw all kinds of things
um
so uh
early on it just
as the clinical trials were still
progressing and then at the very
earliest time when they started
deploying this it became clear that
uh one of the adverse there was two in
particular that were popping up
that my buddies at the FDA who were
outside of the review branch
uh that I was having weekly zooms with
uh said we're being flagged and I was
hearing it popping up from other
Physicians
one was uh
myocarditis
which uh the FDA and the CDC denied
and the Israelis denied that's the story
uh
and how that how that finally came
became public uh and the other one
was reactivation of latent DNA viruses
uh um shingles being a notable example
um and uh so there's a number of these
large herpes-like DNA viruses that exist
in our bodies for most of us
cytomegalovirus is another one
Epstein-Barr virus is a major one
and generally your T cells keep these
guys you can think of it as Pandora's
Box keeps the lid shut
um by you know T Cell suppression
and if you if you pull that suppression
off the top pops open and and all the
nasties fly out of Pandora's Box I think
is a good way to think about these
latent DNA viruses and it was clear that
that was happening after the Jab
uh it's it's one of the major it appears
now to be one of the major causes of the
kind of
shorter term short to intermediate term
uh long coveted symptoms particularly
Epstein-Barr virus
uh so that's what I was referring to now
uh
um fast forward to yesterday or the day
before
uh when uh Veritas dropped this third
video uh from Dr Walker uh I assume now
formerly uh Pfizer uh uh direct
worldwide director of mRNA vaccine or
mRNA strategies uh
in which he talks about the uh
hypothalamic uh pituitary gonadal axis
um
that what he's basically saying there is
that Pfizer believes that the menstrual
irregularities are really kind of the
tip of the iceberg and that this thing
is damaging a fundamental aspect of your
endocrine system your endocrine system
controls your energy controls your sex
drive it controls all kinds of
development it controls your mental
state whether you're depressed or
excited or whatever it controls your
digestion I mean it's your endocrine
system is hugely important and uh it you
know endocrine abnormalities can be
associated with cardiac problems
uh and uh they can absolutely they are
absolutely endocrine fluctuations uh
impact on your immune function
so now now we have in addition to the
huge laundry list we already had of
potential causes you know in terms of
the pathophysiology for why we're seeing
these
uh immunologic suppression phenotypes
particularly the more people get jabbed
uh but now we have another one which is
the damage to the hypothalamic pituitary
uh adrenal axis
so so where where are we at right now I
mean every year we are deep in a hole
and continuing to dig
I mean I mean how concerned so I'm not
vaxxed the the two guys that are in this
room that work for me are not vaxxed one
of the reasons I did not get vaxxed was
because oh first off I'm relatively
young and healthy and take good care of
myself but the more that they pushed for
some reason that was igniting something
in me and I just could not give in to
that and and you know the other part Dr
Malone was that when they really were
pushing this idea of the employer
mandates I kept thinking well I don't
have a I don't have a thousand employees
but even if I did what right would I
have to say to somebody you have to
inject yourself with something to work
for me yeah so so clearly you were never
going to be a major CEO of a large
American corporation because you have a
conscience I suppose that ship has
sailed I got a couple small businesses
I'm doing okay but but having having
heard everything you've said here
especially these last few minutes I mean
people have now some people have gotten
five or six Jabs uh peop we know that
people are getting shingles and
myocarditis and I have a young friend
with heart problems I was on Rogue and I
said those three little words
uh that caused Google and all of Silicon
Valley I like I know it was black I can
do it Mass formation psychosis yeah so
uh a good fraction of the world is
hypnotized they they have succumbed so
here's how I like to frame this
uh
because I'm really trying to focus on
healing
I'm a physician I mean I could have I
could have gone into developing nuclear
warheads like my dad did or or spy
equipment like my father-in-law did no I
want to go into medicine I want to heal
people
um
the whole world has been subjected to
three years of military-grade
psychological operations that it
basically is fifth generation Warfare
Battlefield tactics that have been
deployed designed for fighting Al Qaeda
um deployed against our own citizens
okay so military-grade psyops deployed
particularly in the five eyes countries
Great Britain United States Canada New
Zealand and Australia
this spy Alliance that is one of the
most powerful organizations in the world
and uh for some reason those are the
countries that seem to have had the most
egregious authoritarian responses
and censorship Etc
so uh
so everybody has been subjected to
military grade
information Warfare technology
and some of us like yourself
reacted to it and said oh no if they're
pushing this hard this can't be good I'm
I'm out
um or whatever the reason was that
caused people to wake up Matthias tells
the story that for him it was gradual
Matthias Desmond he's been teaching Mass
formation in the work of Hana aren't and
Gustav Le ball he's a professor this is
what he teaches and and he didn't
realize at first it kind of gradually
dawned on him as things were going along
you know he said holy moly well that's
not what he said um but you get the
picture
um uh what's happening is exactly what
I've been teaching and underneath my
nose and I didn't even realize it
so my point is
everybody has been subjected to this
um something like 15 to 25 percent of
people
uh were resistant to it or woke up
um
and the rest for whatever reason
we're not able to fight off the
psychological warfare that was deployed
against them
should we hate them
or should we say you know first off we
can kind of
Pat ourselves in the back a little bit
good boy
you resisted the psyops that's nice
right
um but I argue
you know and this does not apply let's
say gently to Tony fauci and uh sure
Jacinda Arden Arden and Justin Trudeau
and uh Rachelle wolinsky and you know we
can go on and on with the names Tedros
uh I'm not saying those folks but for
the folks that you meet in the grocery
store that are still wearing face
nozzles the people who got duped and and
uh who are putting face nozzles on their
little kids and everything
um and even the ones that said just ugly
ugly stuff
you know they were they were so wrapped
up in the tribalism
that they they said some there's some
pretty nasty things and some pretty
nasty policies oh you can't have a heart
transplant if you don't take the jab or
we're you know we people that haven't
taken the jab should be allowed to die
or they should be put into camps or you
know we can go on and on with the ugly
ugly stuff that was said I argue that
for the most part those poor souls were
were victims of a psychological Warfare
campaign that was deployed on them and
if we think of it that way we might be
able to open our hearts to them and if
we don't open our hearts we can't bring
them over to our side we can never
convince them by hating them
um and we need them we need the
persuadable middle if we're going to win
this we're going to you know not have to
live under the thumb of Klaus Schwab and
uh all of his minions uh we need each
other we don't need to be split apart so
that's that's my uh my preaching on uh
on the propaganda and uh fifth
generation Warfare story that has you
know all of us have been subjected to
it's kind of nice I mean you spent your
life trying to heal through science and
now you're trying to heal heal through I
suppose something that's a little more
spiritual perhaps
um I I should probably end it there but
but I do want to ask you one one more
thing because that does feel like the
sort of positive ending but but now
having all of this said how worried are
you that Millions I don't know how many
hundreds of millions of people
throughout the world have taken this
vaccine
we're seeing the vaccine injuries many
people have taken you know the fifth
booster or whatever it might be and that
the Litany of health problems that we're
going to see and then what would could
be emotional problems and all of the
other stuff that that were just at the
beginning basically of of the damage of
this stuff
that almost has nothing to do with covet
itself
so uh you didn't finish the sentence how
worried are you about oh so you're
saying
how worried are you that we're at the
beginning of finding out what what
really the repercussions of the vaccines
uh I'm I'm I'm I I'm not worried I know
it to be true
um uh
um that's that's a fact uh
you know I tour with folks like Ryan
Cole
as Ryan says the the cells don't lie
um what he sees on his glass slide isn't
fake
uh it's not a deep fake and the cancers
are popping up
uh there's there's a lot of things going
on here and and now this uh hypothalamic
pituitary adrenal axis issue
um
Dr Walker In a Moment of clarity uh
in his own Twisted way uh in that last
video
um basically gave us a pre-read on on
the situation he said can you imagine
there's whites I'm paraphrasing if
there's a widespread Global damage and
we've damaged a whole Genera the whole
Next Generation uh uh he's his and his
response to that was I would have to
take Pfizer off my resume
um I I I the you know the violin is uh
microscopic that I'm gonna have to play
for that but um yeah be that as it may
even even Dr Walker
recognizes that the uh
civil
the the disruption in the fabric of of
Civil Society
will be huge I I am
as I I've traveled over 400 000 miles
last year on commercial air and then
privates also
a lot of time seeing a lot of people
and unfortunately it's not slowing down
this year I wish it was
um uh and
um
there is a deep anger right now
it is it is I often uh refer to Yates uh
Second Coming
and the slouching Beast towards
Bethlehem
there there is slouching Beast is out
there
and uh
and it things could get very very ugly
uh and
um we absolutely do not need violence
uh
uh it will it will be met with
overwhelming Force
uh it's absolutely not what we need
right now but
um a lot of people are really really
angry and they're getting angrier
and meanwhile uh Pfizer and the
governments and the World Health
Organization and the weft are all
digging in and they kind of are in our
face uh basically
uh like I say telling us to go pound
sand
um you know Justin Trudeau Etc so you
know New Zealand those poor souls uh
they finally get out under Jacinda Arden
and they get somebody who's even worse
it's just incredible
and they're a tiny Island that could
have
dealt with this in a completely
completely different way so give me
something look we could do this first
off you're welcome to come back anytime
to to amplify anything that you want to
talk about in the future of course
um but but try to help me end this in a
way that's going to give people a little
positivity I mean we had to sort of
reach out to your neighbor but yeah I'm
gonna do the book pump thing
yeah okay lies my government told me in
the better future coming what better
future what the heck is he talking about
what I hear all over the world
is the emergence of uh belief
that
um there is
a a path forward that can
um potentially enable us to fulfill more
of our potential as a human species
in a world that rather than becoming
this centralized uh totalitarian
uh I argue fascist or we could call it
corporatist if you want to use nice nice
words
um
Marxist uh utilitarian
uh fourth Industrial Revolution
transhumanism world that that the world
economic Forum wants to shape and thrust
on us
there is another way
um in its movement towards
uh networks of decentralized communities
which in a way is what those those rich
white guys 250 years ago came up with
you know they were pretty smart they did
a whole lot of thinking and reading
uh and they were trying to solve a
problem that's not so different from the
one we face right now only on a smaller
scale
and uh I think they came up with some
pretty good stuff uh in the form of the
uh Declaration of Independence
Constitution Bill of Rights and the
whole idea of a federalist government in
which the the nation state has very
limited powers uh in in authority and
responsibility for things like external
defense and regulating interstate
commerce
um I think what we all what I hear
except for the monopolists you know I
can't speak for Bill Gates but for the
likes it for you and my eye what I hear
again and again is people just kind of
want to be left alone and live their
lives
uh and not told what to do and not told
that they have to uh you know keep have
digital ideas attached to their carbon
credits and you know forced to uh have a
uh social credit score in order to uh
get a mortgage or buy a car or you know
whatever the hell
um uh we just you know guys just leave
us alone
let us let us teach our own kids don't
force
we would not even go there all this
other garbage on our children right yeah
that's that's a whole other time a
feeling I know your feelings and and
um
uh
and allow us to live in a world in which
we can trade and engage in transactions
with each other uh for goods and
services
um and uh live our lives and I'm told
you know so that's one of the big
focuses the book it's things like you
know start a victory garden Etc and some
practical things about what you can do
about our federal government right now
what's in ongoing and what Trump tried
to do that I think was there was a bunch
of good that Trump tried to do uh
um he's he's unfortunately he can't
control certain aspects of his
personality but he did a lot of good and
he had a lot of good ideas and um
about the government and about the
administrative state
uh and um
I'm not sure
I think personally that we've had these
guys have been planning this since World
War II
and and arguably even earlier than that
and uh we're not going to turn this
around uh in the next two years
uh we may not turn it around during our
generation
but I think it's a worthwhile fight to
fight for the sake of our children
um and uh and I think we can there is a
a there's something out there on the
horizon
of a better way for Humanity to really
fulfill its potential by being able to
work cooperatively
uh but not in a way that's from each
according to his abilities to each
according to his needs
um uh
and and I think that that's the better
future I think we can go there I think
we can build towards it in an
incremental way and the phrase that's
often used is intentional communities
uh and if if you're a fan of galts of of
anarand
um you may have or may not have noticed
the name of my sub stack who is Robert
Malone
right which is direct reference to John
Galt
I'm in golf Gulch over here in Florida
I shouldn't have said that but yeah
there you go
um uh in in I consider our little 50
acres here to be our own personal golf
Gulch
so I think that you're you're what
you're expressing is that you already
have your mind wrapped around the idea
of small intentional communities
and the value that they bring and I
think we have to build a new system kind
of organically within this larger
superstructure that's basically going to
collapse around our ears
in the next few years and hope that we
can weather the storm
and come out the other side and and we
can be the examples for an you know a
new way forward rather than this uh you
know Terminator Matrix uh I mean how
many times do we have to see those
movies okay
that Terminator Matrix Minority Report
idiocracy it's all there Dr Malone you
ended it beautifully I appreciate it and
as I often say to my audience I have
nothing better to do than save the world
I suspect you don't either so enjoy your
50 acres and as I said anytime you want
something Amplified please reach out and
and we'll help as much as we can thank
you thanks for the the time spent
um and look forward to our next chat
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless drivel check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell